that there could be an hour that comes
in your life that is worth more than the
cumulative sum of everything else you've
spent all the time all of the effort all
of the energy that you've spent doing
everything else
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i want to
i put my all in it like no days off on
the road let's travel never looking back
this was like a hit podcast like we're
growing we're doing good and yet sean
your microphone is the most like hood
rat thing i've seen what is that is it
like balanced in there
yeah so there's like you know there's
some way that this is supposed to sit
and then there's the way it actually
sits and uh you know don't mess with
success it's our good luck charm so um
jack we're recording now i think you um
someone i don't know how much you looked
into it but someone sent your team a
little update on or a little description
on what we do
and it looks like you sent an agenda
this looks awesome so i have a feeling
you know what's up a little bit is that
right
yeah i listened to a few of your guys
podcasts i think it's great great
content shawn and i kind of go way back
we used to know each other back in san
francisco in the early days when tech
was getting going there and winter san
francisco
yeah when tuck was in san francisco and
excited to be on thanks for having me
how did you uh how did you guys know
each other i was gonna ask you this um i
i didn't know how much you remembered i
remember pretty vividly
um i was at this time i was running
monkey inferno which was an idea lab or
a sort of startup studio
and uh
i don't know how we got connected but
jack came by the office and i remember
sitting in this conference room
and he was thinking about launching his
own you know sort of like personal
incubator idea factory whatever you want
to call these things what do you call it
jack by the way you call it a startup
studio we go with startup studio just
given that the industry seems to have
gone with that and i remember before the
meeting i like kind of googled like okay
who's this guy and then i saw oh wow
this guy's like done all this stuff he
had he built milo he sold it to ebay
and this was like you know not his first
rodeo
and um and in the meeting i remember you
had like really good questions you had
like because a lot of people like this
idea of a startup studio it sounds
really fun you get to sit around all day
just think of ideas and build them and
like if something hits you know hooray
and uh but you had actually like done a
lot of thought you put a lot of thought
into it and so you asked a bunch of
questions and i remember thinking hey
i've been doing this for a few years i
could share a bunch of insights i
remember everything that i had told you
i was like
hey here's a common trap avoid it go
this way you were like yeah that's why
we're doing it this way you had already
you were sort of two two steps ahead i
remember and i was i remember walking
away being like okay i think this is one
of the few struggle studios that might
actually work and i think it has done so
i think it's one of the few startup
studios that has actually worked you
guys had hymns come out of it which is
like a breakout success public company
and um and what what are some of the
other ones that have come out of atomic
that are big i know there's the
there's some that have sort of spiked
and i'm not sure where they're at now
they didn't kind of go yeah full yeah
like we did
we've uh we've created a ton of
different companies um bungalow has been
doing incredibly well we just announced
a huge raise for that company homebound
which is kind of revolutionizing
construction and how that's done with
the marketplace dynamic replicant which
is using ai to transform call centers
radiant which is kind of um cloud
software for screens for b2b
applications so we kind of touch
all sorts of industries we have now
actually a few dozen companies that
we've started
right so we operate across everything
and a lot of our companies are doing
really well we're we actually try to
keep a lot of our companies stealth
because people have started to try to
copy them and by the time we announce
them they've usually raised pretty
significant funding so
a lot of them are are under wraps but we
tend to do a lot in healthcare and
telemedicine we do a lot in prop tech we
do a lot in fintech education ai and
then marketplaces
what is the like idea process because
you're right you do stay in stealth
for a while i think i feel it feels like
when you come out to market you've
already like the company's already got a
bunch of traction you announce a big
raise at that point
but
what that means is that people are
willing to copy you like if jack's doing
it as an idea it's probably a good
market and a good idea let's just that
if we just use that and we copy that
we're already skipping a bunch of
potential points of failure and um
you know i think everybody thinks
they're a good idea person you actually
seem to be a good idea person so where
does that what's the process what's the
process for ideas um
you know how are you coming up with so
like a high number of good of good
quality ideas
you have you have 600 you have a list of
600 in an evernote doc it's just an
evernote doc right yeah 600.
yeah so you have a lot a lot of ideas
yeah
yeah so
okay multi-part question um
so i think the first
part of this is where do kind of good
ideas come from and i have a view on
this which is a little contrarian and
actually i think where startup studios
and incubators can fall apart which is a
lot of times if you're incubating
companies a temptation is to brainstorm
on ideas so think about things get into
a room whiteboard come up with solutions
and you're kind of coming up with these
contrived solutions to problems that may
or may not exist and that's kind of a
problem you know
versus what we do at atomic is we don't
have brainstorming sessions so we've
been in business for over a decade we've
never had a brainstorming session on
ideas which is kind of crazy right so
what we do is we observe problems in the
world that could be problems that we
have personally problems on our team
problems in our portfolio that our
companies have that create enterprise
companies and in that case we observe
the problems we see a pattern we
actually build the product to solve it
we deploy it across our portfolio we
have built-in customers we we dog food
it we make sure that it works within our
portfolio and then once we know it works
then we release it to the world but it's
really a problem first kind of mentality
and then solving the problem that i
think makes us stand out and a little
bit different from other people that
have attempted this and
i uh in terms of the 600 ideas and where
they've come from
it turns out our view of the world is
like it's actually fundamentally very
broken there's just a lot of stuff in
the world that could be improved and
that doesn't mean that everything's like
broken broken right like it just means
that there's there is an opportunity in
many many facets of light and many parts
of the economy to up level things
and this could be in just like everyday
parts of life this could be in going to
the doctor's office this could be in
commuting to work this could be in you
know interacting with a company or
running a sales team or you know
something like that
you just observe all these things and
think wow
that doesn't seem you know that seems a
little bit broken there there's probably
a better way and then i just got in the
habit of writing those down and now that
list has grown to over 600 and that's a
seed that we use to start companies out
of at atomic and i have um a whole bunch
of questions that i like i i i was
telling you i watched a lot of your
interviews so i i understand a little
bit about your process and i want to ask
you about that but before you did this
so you're 30 are you 34 now i'm 35 now
you're 35. so before you were doing
atomic your first big win was milo you
sold that for like 75 million at 24
right yep
stayed there at ebay
sam do you know who his dad is i do
comms core yeah so so i didn't know that
until i was doing research because we
had met i just thought oh he's kind of
like a whiz kid and i love contour
behind every whiz kid is some unique
childhood i think where you get exposed
to something so so jack so your dad
started comscore is that right with ceo
uh i don't know if you still ceo and you
were working there like at age 12 or
something crazy is that
right thanks yeah um yeah i had a
an interesting childhood where
i got exposed to entrepreneurship at a
young age my dad was an immigrant he
came to the u.s literally without a
dollar to his name from wherever
he was born in lebanon and then he
actually
went to college in france studying
science and engineering and math he came
to the us phd in math at mit and he
literally didn't have a dollar to his
name so he slept on a concrete basement
floor at mit in a sleeping bag i was
born while he was there in boston
and then you know he took math and he
applied it to business he actually
invented
all these really cool new forms of
marketing which at the time were
revolutionary he ended up winning these
international marketing awards for them
ended up getting promoted in the company
that he joined and eventually became
president of it and then decided to
become an entrepreneur can you imagine
the world dream i mean he was basically
born at the bottom of the third world he
rose to the top of the first world
started a company sold it and then when
i was 12 or 13 he said jack i'm going to
start a company that's going to measure
everything everyone does on the internet
and make sense of it do you want to join
it and i joined it as the third person
as a software engineer and i learned how
to write code did he give you equity
uh
well
so he was like do you want cash for
equity i said equity i don't want cash
give me equity so i took the equity and
it ended up working out also
child labor laws meant he couldn't pay
me cash so
i had to get the equity and at its peak
it was worth it like he took it public
it was worth like 6 billion or something
like that like many billions yeah it
ended up being worth billions at its
peak um he basically yeah he grew it on
his own took it public it did really
well and then you know two or three
years after it went public he decided i
don't want to be a public company ceo
and he got off of that started doing
investing and being on boards but i got
to see that grow just from like an idea
in my parents sitting room
to you know thousand plus person company
to public company and i just got hooked
so i started starting companies at age
15 and i've just been hooked it's just
been in my dna ever since technology has
been in my dna
how long were you when you went when it
went public
hmm that's a good question i was in
college so i probably was like 19 or 20
or something like that so he gave you
shares when you were 13 when you were 20
what did they end up becoming worth
were you like the richest 20 year old
there is the podcast is called my first
million you might have been the youngest
the youngest person to make your first
million uh if that math adds up
you know
my dad
was a is a very fair person and that
would have been nepotism to give me an
unfair amount of shares
he gave me what i deserved which i was a
12 or 13 year old that didn't know how
to code so
i got basically paid the equivalent of
like close to minimum wage and shares
which is kind of what i deserved right
but it ended up being worth a lot of
money and it was great and yeah it was a
good taste of equity and you start milo
it it's a quiet was it acquired for 75
billion
right so you're 24. so correct just
massive success milo ends up becoming a
pretty big deal like a main part of ebay
you work on a a bunch of big parts at
ebay you become this kind of big shot
like you kind of climb out about this
because in the last two years but
basically me so i got acquired uh we got
acquired by twitch to like you know go
from uh
a little start up to okay it's a 2000
person company sam just got acquired his
company just got acquired by hubspot i
don't know how many how many places
hubspot have
probably three thousand i think three
thousand employees and so uh and i know
i would say like the default path for
entrepreneurs and i know because i
talked to a bunch of them during the
acquisition process of like all right
what's the next year of my life going to
look like
you know what's your advice to me and i
got a whole range of idea of sort of
opinions but i would say the common the
default path was sort of like
look
somebody who's like you true
entrepreneur at heart it's gonna be hard
for you to be in a big company for a
long time uh you could choose to either
like just not play the game you kind of
like coast and just do your own thing
maybe do build a couple interesting
products while you're there and then
bounce whenever you're ready or you like
try to play the game you try to climb
the ladder a bit and uh and actually
like figure out what what this looks
like there's a different game than the
startup game you're you're not zero to
one you're sort of in the one one-to-n
phase of things and you know it's all
about sort of about management of a
large organization
um
and i think most entrepreneurs go the
first route that i just mentioned but it
seems like you actually kicked ass at
ebay like i remember reading some
article where you were basically like a
vp or something you were the the mvp
really you were like the the guy who's
helping turn this thing around i think
it was like part of a bigger story of
hey ebay is turning itself around but um
you seem to have done extremely well
talk about that is that something where
you what was your approach when you got
acquired and is that true
yeah yeah how much of that story is true
yeah so
you know it's interesting
first of all it's definitely true it
wasn't told when i was at ebay
partially because i don't like that much
attention and i don't claim credit for a
lot of things while i was there i was
just catching up with like a reporter
that i liked and i told him this story
and he was like this is amazing why
hasn't anyone written about this it
ended up getting written up and
eventually the story got told but
um
yeah i'm a pretty impact motivated
person overall and i had just heard all
these stories about founder friends that
had sold their companies and they they
sell to the acquirer and they languish
and they actually kind of become
depressed they're just kind of like they
lose their mojo they're just like what
am i doing what's my life becoming
they'd almost become like robotic
and i was just like you know what life's
short like i'm let me figure out how to
use this experience for the good of the
company of me i'm proud of what i built
i want to see it succeed let's figure
out how to do that and i went and you
know there's some funny stories about
things that we did while we were at ebay
to try to maintain our culture
we at one point i rallied the troops we
had this house they tried to put us in
cubicles i had the whole company rise up
and go and rip down the cubicles and
throw it on the front lawn and we almost
got in trouble and kicked off campus and
all sorts of crazy stuff but
i basically took the approach of like
look what's the worst thing that can
happen they can fire me if i get fired i
don't really care so i might as well
just go for it and try to do great
things while i'm here right and what's
what's a great thing that i can do well
there's a bunch of products that ebay
can build i like building products i'm
an entrepreneur i haven't tried building
multiple products at once what if i use
this time at ebay to try to put together
multiple teams under me and try my hand
at building multiple products at once
and see if i'm any good at that versus
just working on one product and i
convinced the ceo to let me do that and
give me a shot at it
and the majority of what we built was
hitting and like a lot of it was driving
press cycles and the stock price the
biggest thing i did i convinced the ceo
to do on a friday
that night i convinced six people to
cancel their next two weeks fly with me
to sydney australia rent an airbnb turn
it into a hacker house and we built the
entire thing in two weeks there's
actually a story written about this
online and it ended up becoming the feed
in the homepage of ebay and 130 million
people were using it nine months later
um as like the primary discovery
mechanism on the site and and and after
that you started a couple things before
atomic i think right and those things
there i feel like when i was researching
your story they're kind of like
footnotes like they're not like major
parts and yet i researched them they
were
really successful uh like a couple
software companies right
yeah
started a bunch of software companies
that are still successful they're kind
of part of atomic is kind of how we
consider them everything's kind of been
folded into one umbrella at at uh one
point or another
the the other thing that i would say
that is a lesson that we learned and
sean i don't know if you remember when
we talked about startup studios about
this but
one trap you can have with startup
studios is when you have hundreds of
ideas and when i left ebay i had 250
potential ideas for my next company
is the temptation is to try them all and
the thing that we did at atomic is we
only did one the first year to the
second three the third
for the fourth we really paced ourselves
and i think you know now we're at the
point where we can do
10 or 12 a year
um but that was kind of part of that
pacing process i remember three of those
traps i want to say them because i'm
sure there's somebody out here listening
who who
would be curious um
i remember one was exactly what you said
which was focus so
uh
the theme is basically startup studios
are great they have a bunch of
advantages but you don't want to lose
the natural advantages that startups
have and so startups have desperation
and focus those are two of the core
ingredients of a startup and i said you
know shiny object syndrome is a trap
when you have an idea lab you could do
exactly what you said you could just go
in a whiteboard brainstorm it that's
kind of your job and then you take one
of those ideas it sounds semi-plausible
and paul graham i think calls these
sitcoms startup ideas it's like you come
up with a a a kind of a
manufactured story for a sitcom like oh
a guy and a girl fall in love in college
and then you know their jobs take them
across the country and they break up
right like you come up with these
manufactured ideas and then the second
thing is
because you have multiple ideas going at
once when you're doing
at the beginning when you're doing one
it starts to hit some rough patches or
plateaus or just things get challenging
like every idea does
um
well that shiny object over there is
unproven that one might be easier let's
just go and you either intentionally or
unintentionally start to shift your
focus away from the hard thing that you
should really be pushing through and
start just focusing on other shiny
objects the second one was desperation
you you had said something smart you you
go
we're gonna fund the team i think we've
said for nine months you go then their
job is to raise the series a in nine
months um and i was like that's great
because if otherwise in an ideal lab
these things can just languish forever
you could just keep them it's sort of
this feeling that you know if not this
month and next month no problem and
you're like
the people working on this are only
going to work on this one project their
project needs to raise money or
sorry guys it's a bust and like of
course you would probably recycle the
best talent into the next idea but i
liked that having a uh sort of a
deadline and a do or die moment of like
you either proved your [__] or you
didn't that was the second uh second one
i remember and the third was you're like
we're gonna focus on b2b initially and
not consumer stuff because we know a
bunch of pain points that we've had as
entrepreneurs or our companies have and
so we can kind of scratch our own niche
and not try to make the next hit social
network and frankly it's probably
so much easier although himself was a
consumer company so you know you know
but maybe who knows i don't want to pry
but maybe you're scratching your own
it's there too
well you know it
no
that was a bunch of that was a hair loss
company i still have my hair as i said
it was a hair loss
he was about to jack was about to skip
that one over and then he was like i
gotta try to let it go
um
you know that
a vc told me
who i really respect
that the way you make your money in the
venture business
is b2b those are your singles and
doubles typically and consumer can be
your home runs that can be your
lightning in the bottle and you should
plan your portfolio accordingly who said
that
um
that's a good question
i think it was one of the managing
partners from general catalyst if i
remember correctly um and they're great
we do some work with them they're pretty
fantastic
and
you know since then b2b has actually
been able to become home runs right
additionally right like the valuations
on some of these b2b companies is
absolutely astronomical but the great
thing about doing b2b is you can talk to
the customer and you can trust what they
say
and that is not necessarily true for
consumer consumers you can talk to them
and you almost have to read between the
lines with what they say you can't trust
what they say you can trust what they do
you have to kind of run them through the
product you have to look at the data and
see what they do but what they do is
actually usually different than what
they say and what works is not always
what they say is going to work part of
that is consumers don't know in their
mind what they need they don't know it's
hard they can't dream it up so it's a
very different practice creating
consumer companies from b2b companies
but to address your other point sean
of the nine months and you know having
companies raise on their own that is
like a purposeful element that we
designed atomic in
which is we tried to design atomic to be
uncomfortable
at the atomic level so companies are
pushed out and people are pushed out of
atomic and there's not this effect where
people just stay in the incubator
forever because it's dangerous to do
that and
that is is it nine months and 300 000 is
that right or 250 000 or something
um
so we have
multiple stages of investment
the first check that we'll write to kind
of get something going and do some
initial research and homework is around
a quarter million dollars but it could
range from a hundred thousand to four
hundred thousand
and then if that goes well we can write
a check that's usually two million
dollars but again it could be one to
four million dollars
and then from there
we can actually write a check that could
be three to eight million dollars um
that sometimes we do with other vcs
sometimes we do on our own kind of
depends on the circumstances depends on
the needs of the company and what we
need to get to the next set of
milestones um but that's kind of how it
works now that's been evolving over our
funds and our first fund it was smaller
so we obviously only did like the early
rounds which is what sean is describing
and then as it's gotten bigger we're
able to get the companies further which
is why we can keep them stealth longer
and now when they come out they usually
have raised these really big rounds did
you when you when you were starting this
how much of your own money did you put
up to do this and were you like all
right uh you know i made this much money
i'm willing to lose a million dollars
over the next two years to see if i can
make this work
yeah it's a good question so
my general philosophy with things is
you shouldn't sell what you wouldn't
also buy so i wanted to prove to myself
that this would work before raising
outside capital so
the first year or so of atomic i did it
with my own capital which was roughly on
the order of what you described and then
once i was convinced okay
i think this is working i think we can
pull this off i think this model is
going to work and then we raised our
first fund and our first fund was you
know roughly the first first part of the
first fund was roughly a 10 million
dollar vehicle that was primarily
individuals and we had some great
founders of venture capital firms
involved like mark andreessen and
um idan senkid and peter thiel and
people like that that helped us a lot in
the early days
and that helped us prove out the model
from there and since then we've raised
much much larger funds you have a couple
of things on the agenda that i
i want to know the answer to and one is
what you just said you've uh andreason
backed your your fund chris dixon david
sacks peter thiel
and you said
on here he says some of some of the
learnings from some of these kind of
like pretty amazing people these are
some of the like architects of like you
know the modern silicon valley um
i guess do you have any like fun stories
anecdotes or lessons learned that are
you know
not what's you know i guess like just
absolute common sense where you just say
we all already know that but what have
you learned from some of these guys
that's that's been that stood out to you
or stuck with you and add in josh
kushner on there too because he
interests me as well he which he almost
has a model like yours
yeah he also starts companies i love
josh josh is fantastic um
wow
well those are great people
the first thing i'd say and you know
this is just a general thing is like
there are some amazing people out in the
world i'm surprised how many people
don't approach them and just ask them
for advice and mentorship
and that's something
that was a major way that i learned
throughout my career and i'm so thankful
to have had those people in my life and
grateful for everything that i learned
from them
you know i'd say
maybe going going through some of them
one of the things that i learned
from mark andreessen
was actually a really interesting story
about peter thiel um that led to a
really really big insight that i had
that has kind of driven a lot of my
decision making since then
um which is this concept that
time exists on this massive power law
basis and um
you know they were having this
conversation apparently mark was telling
me
where
peter was talking to mark and he was
talking about you know this big moment
where he made this investment in mark
zuckerberg and he made this investment
in in facebook
and you know he said
you know listen mark i worked so hard my
whole life to be able to get into
stanford i really worked hard in in high
school and i did this and i did that and
all these extracurriculars i finally got
into stanford i got into stanford i
crushed it at stanford i tried to get
you know the best grades while i was
there i did really well to get into
stanford law school i got into stanford
law school i did really well while i was
there i you know was really crushing it
while i was there because i wanted to
get into the best law firm i got into
the best law firm while i was there you
know i realized it wasn't for me but
that enabled me to start a hedge fund
from there i met max levchin i got the
opportunity to go run paypal i ran that
it went public you know ended up being
merging with ebay it led me to start
clearing capital this hedge fund which
was kind of a dream that i wanted to do
for a long time
all of this effort all of this time all
of this energy
everything that i had done up until this
point in my life
got me one hour with mark zuckerberg
and that hour was worth more than the
cumulative sum
of all those other hours that i'd spent
in my life
and
that is a crazy mind-blowing fact if you
think about that that there could be an
hour that comes in your life that is
worth more than the cumulative sum of
everything else you've spent all the
time all of the effort all of the energy
that you've spent doing everything else
and i think that can be true for
everyone so
looking out for those kind of like power
law time moments or those power hours
can be so important and i believe that
they exist and sometimes they're in
plain sight so thinking about those
critically how do you put yourself in
those positions where you can discover
those kinds of opportunities and how do
you almost engineer your calendar so
that you can create
those opportunities for yourself i think
it's an interesting
question what's an example of that for
you do you have an hour
is there something that stands out to
you that's like your version of that
hour with zuck or
how do you engineer it
yeah it's a really interesting question
so
this is something i've never met jeff
bezos i'm a huge fan of his but one of
the things that he does that i think
that i adopted that i think is a really
really cool practice
is
you take a look at your prior week and
how all of your time is spent
and you you look at your calendar you
look at each block each half an hour
each hour and you you basically i
basically modified a little bit what he
does but you ask the question
for all of these things that i did last
week what are the things where if i
hadn't done this thing nothing would
have changed
and you cross it off the list
and if things keep getting crossed off
that list
you probably shouldn't be doing them
you should probably find a way to get
out of those kinds of meetings or
replace yourself in those kinds of
meetings or hire someone perhaps to you
know take those kinds of meetings for
you
because they're not as productive and
then really circle
the things that really really mattered
you know there could be within a week if
if it in a lifetime you can have an hour
that's worth the cumulative some of the
hours you can certainly have that in a
week right you can have that in a month
you can have that in a year so really
training your mind
toward you know what those things are um
and circling them and having that
pattern recognition can make a lot of
sense
um
i like that so that's kind of i used to
have a job that was kind of like a
shitty job it paid really well but i
just didn't like it
and i remember talking to my friend
there and i go
he's like why don't you like it like
it's all good like it's an easy job
we're making great money we're you know
they really respect us they like us
what's the problem and i was like the
problem is i feel like if i didn't come
here today nothing would change and if i
you know and then you boil that down
it's like if i don't do anything this
hour definitely nothing's gonna change
and we called it uh it's kind of like
you said you look at all those blocks
and you sort of figure out which blocks
matter and we literally said the same
thing and we called it the jenga law
which was you know in a tower of jenga
blocks if you remove some blocks the
tower's totally fine and then other
blocks are like the key linchpins and
there's some some point where you remove
too many and the whole tower tips over
and it falls and so you you don't want
to remove those anchors but there are
plenty of sort of useless blocks that
are in there and if you take them out
you make space then something
interesting can happen and so we started
doing that i started i first started
with an hour i said okay every day from
1 pm to 2 p.m i'd do nothing it wasn't
to be lazy it was to test what happens
and then of course nothing happened
nobody noticed your office space moment
yeah exactly and i took half a day off
i'm just going to do nothing for the
second half to stay see what happens
nothing happened then i just stopped
coming to work for like two weeks right
and finally by like the fourth week it
was like they you know they were like
hey what the heck where are you uh we
noticed that these things were behind
and what job was this it was a job i had
in australia my after my first company
kind of got like aqua hired i was
working for this thing and
yeah it was it was a fun it was again a
nice place but it really taught me that
like
one thing that matters to me is
that my hours matter like i want my
hours to matter
that doesn't mean i want to work super
hard but when i do do something i want
it to matter and i started doing what
you're doing which is like
recognizing that it's not linear every
hour is not equal um we kind of get
trained this way right you're going to
work monday through friday nine to five
if there's this assumption that monday
equals thursday that you know the first
hour of the eight hour day is the same
as the fourth hour but they're
definitely not in productivity or
importance
yeah yeah absolutely i think that that's
absolutely right
i want to ask you about very specific
ideas so in the pomp podcast basically
you said something i entirely agree with
which is distribute or i don't know if
you said it or if it was discussed
distribution over ideas so you look at
um you want to know um how do i get
early customers and can this actually
scale some of the ways that you do that
is you look at the payback period so you
try to see you try to get that as low as
possible so if i acquire a customer how
much how long does it take to get my
money back
you said the best in class is three
months you also said that the ltv to cac
best in class is five uh meaning uh you
acquire a customer for a dollar they're
worth five dollars to you um
and you also said that you have a very
at this point very strict standards for
launching companies so you said you have
600 ideas you can launch up to 10 now
and that's many years into this so
what i want to talk about is
what ideas didn't cross this threshold
but in your head you think it could have
or if the right person does this it
definitely maybe could work or maybe it
couldn't
meet some of those benchmarks but it's
still pretty cool and pretty good what
uh can you tell me some ideas that keep
you up at night honorable mentions
honorable mention
good question um
that was a good question by the way
let me let me think through that i mean
there there have been plenty plenty
plenty over the years to think through
i'm just trying to think through some
worth calling take out your evernote and
just scroll i know i know
click share and then add say i'm at
sampar.com yeah totally
okay well i'll give you some examples so
one example is um
all right so talk about problem solution
so we got this we got this new
office in in letterman and the presidio
for those of you who don't know in san
francisco it's kind of like a national
park there's like a lot of trees around
and we got this new office
and i was just a mess in this office i
was sneezing i was feeling awful like
every day and i just had these horrible
allergies and i couldn't get rid of
these allergies and i like it took me
three or four months to get an
appointment at an allergist was it like
mold or something
well i had no idea i was like what could
this be like obviously there's something
new about this environment so i went to
this allergist i got tested and of all
the possible things i could be allergic
to it was the one tree that was growing
outside the window of my new office that
i could not move that was like protected
by the city anyway so i i had to deal
with it
in the process
you know what are your options in terms
of getting treated for allergies well
you can get allergy shots which are
painful you have to go every week they
have to be scheduled they're expensive
like they take a lot of we're talking
about time power law i don't want to be
driving around the city getting these
allergy shots every week
or you can do something called
sublingual immunotherapy so basically
like there's two ways to get these
allergens and increasing quantities into
your immune system so that you you get
used to them one is through an injection
another is by putting them under your
tongue both ways they get into your
bloodstream
i i said well i want to do the thing
under your tongue you can do it at home
it's a drop a day in the morning that
seems a lot easier so i did that and i
got it and it completely cured me of my
allergies
and i was like this is amazing why
doesn't everybody have this
look at all these kids they're going
they're getting these allergy shots you
go and you look and structurally it's
really messed up because the allergists
get paid for giving these allergy shots
that's why there's so many allergy shots
you go to the allergist they bill your
insurance
so every visit you do they get paid
versus every sublingual drop you do at
home they're not getting paid so that's
actually you know normally the perfect
setup right for like creating a company
it's like okay let's disrupt there's
this misaligned incentive let's go go
ahead and disrupt this a lot of people
suffering huge pain point
people really really hate their
allergies
so we went you know we found a
compounded pharmacy we found like supply
chain this is actually pretty difficult
to like source and get right and treat
all these allergies and figure out how
to do vita telemedicine and we went and
we we tested it and just the economics
just don't work and it's just
i think they should work i think it's
dramatically better than getting shots
at the allergist i feel like
i don't understand why this isn't the
way everyone gets cured of their
allergies we attempted to make the world
better by giving everyone this way
of getting cured of their allergies
but we just weren't able to figure it
out and then we tried selling it through
doctors and you know the allergists of
course don't want their revenue stream
to be disrupted of getting the allergy
shots so that's not going to work
so eventually we said you know what we
got a lot of other problems to solve and
opportunity cost is really high what
what about it didn't it work the the
methods were too expensive
just the unit economics yeah we couldn't
we couldn't get the unit economics to
work do you remember how much like what
some of the numbers were
well
let's see
we were trying really we tried a bunch
of different price points in terms of
like the monthly price for these
sublingual drops ranging from like 79 a
month all the way up to like 250 a month
because these are our tests you know
we're testing the pricing that obviously
gets you a gross
margin depending on that price
and then you know there's a cac to
acquire the customer
and the problem in this case was just
the cac was really really high
i don't know if it's you know a new
thing customers don't know about it they
need to be educated maybe they're
skeptical
hard to sell over the internet
i'm not sure but you know we're really
good at producing locax we're really
good at scaling things we just couldn't
figure out how to get the caclo on this
we did a lot of different iterations
and you know the other way that can work
is if the churn is really low and you
just get payments for a long time this
should be it takes about
a year to three years to fully cure
um
but
it just didn't work out the math didn't
work out and you know that's the kind of
thing
the world should be that way it should
be that way and like you can be an
entrepreneur and believe that and i
still believe that but you'll be
knocking your head against a brick wall
forever and get nowhere and there are
other problems like that that you can
solve
that can become huge and it's just
better in our view to work on this so
that's why i've adopted this philosophy
which is exactly what you said which is
distribution's more important than ideas
and we only want to work on ideas that
can achieve mass distribution because
our view is life is short and you know
but for us and our co-founders
we want to you know prize our time and
we only want to work on things that can
reach a lot of customers whether they're
consumers or businesses we want it to
matter
so we we try to validate that as much as
possible up front what are some other
ones that you've done that maybe could
have worked but just missed the mark you
have a different like different bullet
here that you can do if it's hard to
think of that which is patterns for
great company ideas and it says three
ideas to talk about so i'm curious about
those
yeah i'll i'm gonna throw out
another one
that was like a crazier idea that we we
looked into
that i'm just gonna put out there as a
crazy idea maybe someone on this podcast
will do it i still think it's a good
idea um
but
there are some problems with it so i'll
disclose it
so
you know there's all this technology
computer vision etc that's been
developed for autonomous vehicles
so cars self-driving cars so cars they
drive around there's a lot of issues
right like you've got stop signs you've
got stop lights you've got got to be
able to identify colors there's people
coming there's bikes there's all this
stuff in the environment that you you
know there's it's 2d but it's also 3d
you go up you go down there's weather
there's all of this stuff
so we were trying to think
what are some interesting you know ways
that this technology could potentially
be applied and you know a crazy idea
that i had that i had us look into
was what if you created autonomous
fishing vessels
that went out into the ocean and just
fished 24 7.
even through inclement weather and they
had like crazy sonar and like computer
vision underwater and they could find
the fish and they just you know
automatically did all of that
and you know we looked into it and you
know it's it's still such interesting
technology i hope someone does build it
but that there's some structural issues
with it around fishing quotas and
the industry industry capture of that
industry that we could get into at
another time um that kind of make it a
little bit difficult but that's another
idea
um
but anyway yeah i'm happy to we can
discuss that more i'm happy to progress
into the
patterns behind yeah
go to the patterns i'd be curious to
what those are okay cool
sounds good
um
yeah so some patterns
that
i think are kind of tried and true that
are really interesting to to think about
one pattern is
if you take things that
rich people have access to or rich
companies have access to
and you figure out how to democratize
them so you make them more accessible
distributable cheaper and accessible to
everyone
that is a winning formula for creating a
really good company
and part of the reason for that from a
philosophical perspective this is
actually something i learned from mark
andreessen
he has this belief that
human desire is infinite
which is an interesting concept and if
you believe that then people with a lot
of resources and companies with a lot of
resources are willing to spend on the
outer limit of human desire so they're
poking around they're figuring out all
of these things of what's the next thing
on the human desire bubble that could be
discovered
and they might discover something and if
something there really takes hold that
you can then take and give to everyone
everyone might want that and it might be
ready for everyone like one like uber
uber was a classic example of this right
people had private drivers
now everybody can push a button have a
private driver driver pick him up
yeah private driver um with uber
private chef with doordash
private shopper with instacart those are
all you know really good examples
you could even argue you know second
home airbnb
it's kind of like having access to a
second home much in a much cheaper way
and so what's uh what's an idea in that
space so what are some other things that
you've seen that either
very wealthy people or very wealthy
companies have that the rest of us don't
what are some other what are some other
examples in there that you know haven't
looked into it but might be might be
interesting well i think that there
seems to be some kind of a renaissance
happening in fintech partially because
the wealthy seem to have access to
financial planning financial resources
around planning access to the markets
you know there's this whole
99 percent versus the one percent and
people have kind of figured that out and
i think that's why you're seeing this
boom of new companies if you can give
the 99 what the one percent has access
to and the ability to generate wealth i
think that that's actually really
interesting i think there are a lot of
interesting startup ideas that are being
formed there we're starting one or two
um that we think can help empower people
in that area for example
um so that would be you know one example
of of an area that are you gonna do
anything in the wealth advisor space
um
we are kind of tangentially doing things
there i think that there's probably a
lot more to do there
um
you know wealth advisory is a compounded
issue where
even the wealthy when they have access
to wealth advisory
it's not
great it's not great have you heard of
have you heard of adpar sean
no
so i i bet you have jack right out of
par yeah at a par sorry and so at a par
was started by joe lonsdale i think
right um i only know like you know the
wikipedia version but basically it's a
it's kind of like mint.com but for
really wealthy people i actually but
like billionaire wealthy people i
actually don't know what features
necessarily it has
that uh something a little bit what jack
what's it have that's more robust you
know it basically has tracking of like
everything every fund everywhere in the
world every wealth manager all of your
assets but they tend to work more with
wealth managers instead of individuals
but
joe in that company has an in like a big
vision for where that can go um and you
might be able to work with it as an
individual now but that's kind of along
the lines so i could disrupt that so i
work with some of these folks and they
send me like
the jankiest stuff ever and their login
so like morgan stanley the login to like
look at your investments it's horrible
and i was like you guys this is just
absolutely awful like i'm just using
spreadsheets on my own this is really
bad you know i've heard of this adapar
thing and they're like well you know you
can't use that unless you're worth 500
million dollars or like a billion
dollars it's really really expensive
like it's crazy high and i'm like are
you kidding me just like give me a min
dot com login or something and you guys
like become the admin and just like
let's share this you can just tell me
because this is dog [__] and so
i think that um
i think there's a lot of interesting
stuff in that space but to go back to
your point about distribution i think
selling to those people are can be quite
challenging because they're very old
school and they're very conservative but
uh that i was bringing this up to ask
you if that's a space that has been
interesting to you lately because you i
know you're being a little cryptic
because you like to be stealth until you
you go live but so i was trying to i'm
trying to get something out of you
yeah i think it's a really interesting
space i would encourage people to look
into it i think that there is a lot that
can be done there i think there's
dissatisfaction amongst everyone
basically in that space
it's pretty universal a lot of room for
improvement
cool so that's that's one uh pattern for
great ideas so what are the what are the
wealthy companies that people have that
can be democratized and uh and other if
a few people have that desire and
they've pushed out to that limit other
people would want it if you can make it
accessible cheaper and more available to
them that's that's an amazing one i
think there's tons of great ideas there
uh what's another what's other framework
or or sort of pattern you've seen for
great ideas
yeah so one that i think is is pretty
interesting that's also i would put in
like the tried and true bucket
is
if you take something
that
people
consistently do
and they have to do and they feel like
they have to do it
but it takes a lot of steps and or time
and you dramatically simplify it
and you make it a lot faster to
accomplish the same thing that they feel
like they have to do
so some good examples of this would be
for example booking online travel you
know it used to be so hard to do you'd
have to go to so many different sites
the kayak founders had the vision of
let's just pull it all into kayak.com
you go to one site you see it all in one
place they made it really easy and the
case we've said this once which was
anytime there's somebody has 14 tabs
open to do this to do one task that's a
business opportunity is that right
that's a business opportunity yeah i
mean you just watch for that if you ever
see that people are doing a lot of
research there yeah tons of tabs open
it's really arduous that that's an
opportunity
another example of that that we we kind
of found with hims and hers and other
telemedicine companies that we we've
started is going to the doctor's office
you know people need to go to the
doctor's office think of that process
you're calling the doctor's office
you're scheduling an appointment you're
whipping out your calendar you're
putting it on your calendar you're going
to the waiting room you're sitting there
you're getting prescribed something
you're going to walgreens you're waiting
in line for half an hour going around
the store
going home you know this is a big
process and as a result the next
generation kind of doesn't even really
engage with the health care system you
know close to nine out of 10 of them
don't even know who their doctor is and
or they haven't even gone
so you know telemedicine takes that
process and makes it a five-minute
process where you can do it on your
phone and go through and
get treated for whatever condition that
you have
um i think another interesting example
of that is selling your house
people need to sell their house right
and it's a really hard long arduous
process fraught with a lot of anxiety
and things like that open door came
along and said hey come to this website
tell us what your house is and we'll
make you an offer to buy it
and you can sell it right now
and
you know not everyone has to do that and
not everyone does do that but enough
people do it that it created a really
really big company that's doing really
well
so those are some some interesting and
you guys are doing that now with open
store right uh which i gotta say is it
is a truly great idea i remember when i
first started it i texted my friend and
i said uh i i didn't even say how great
this idea is i just only said why are we
not doing this uh because i was like
this is that good of an idea selling
your company selling your e-commerce
store in this case
um
takes so much effort so much work and
the data is all there right like i'm
assuming i don't actually know how it
works i'm assuming it's sort of like
clear bank or whatever where you can
plug into their shopify you can plug
into their facebook ad account you can
plug into their bank or whatever and and
with those you know three sources of
data you can get a basically like a
health score and a value of this of this
of this shop and make them an offer and
they don't have to go most of them don't
even know like at least with a house
it's painful but you kind of know what
you're supposed to do to do it yeah at
nine out of ten friends i talked to who
have an e-commerce store don't even know
what you would do if you wanted to sell
i don't even know what whose door do i
knock on what do i need to have ready
and so therefore i just i'm just not
gonna do it and um and it's like the
open door thing where not everybody's
gonna do this but
sure if open door captures i don't know
what they modeled out but you know one
percent three percent five percent of
all house sales like multi-billion
dollar company same thing for for open
source so i'm super super bullish to the
point where i was like what am i doing
with my life that i'm not doing this
idea this makes total sense
oh man well thanks for saying that don't
worry i'm not going to copy you but
keith and i are having a ton of fun ton
of fun building out that company um here
in miami that's been a blast
building a a great team a huge team and
yeah it solves this pain point in a
market where it's really hard to sell
your company
and all you need to do is come to a
website we give you a price and you can
sell your company and it's it's really
interesting we have an amazing data
science team we're hiring really
aggressively if anyone wants to join
it's
you know anyone who joins that team it's
such an unbelievable team i think it's
going to create this
almost
miami mafia so to speak around here of
amazing people i think it's an
exceptional opportunity and
scaling really quickly
so that's been a lot of fun thanks for
saying that in another pod you said
something like you have this list of
ideas but every once in a while you'll
meet someone who's so amazing that you
say to them well what's your idea and
how can we just tell me what your idea
is and we'll partner with you or you
know you said something like that i
don't know if it was exactly that
what attributes
would a person have to have in order for
you to say that to them
yeah so we're
we're open
you know the ideas don't necessarily
have to come from us we're totally open
if people want to bring their ideas and
co-found companies with us
um
we just kind of ask that they be baked
off in a process and that the data wins
we're just such big believers in this
distribution over ideas thing that as
long as we if we test our idea and the
distribution's great fantastic let's go
let's do it together that sounds great
but otherwise you know we just ask that
we do that kind of testing process that
we like to do
but some of the attributes that we look
for
you know we really like people that are
just tenacious they just wake up in the
morning they want to play offense they
have three things they want to get done
by the end of the day and they get them
done and they knock down walls
and they're creative they have a lot of
raw intelligence they inspire other
people they can hire they're charismatic
um
you know it depends on the idea right
like some ideas that are more
technically oriented obviously you're
looking for a slightly different profile
versus ideas that are maybe more
you know sales or product oriented so we
are a little bit
founder idea or product fit as well we
do consider that but
um yeah those are some of the attributes
that we look for in people but sometimes
you meet someone and there's just a
really strong connection
you know you have these high bandwidth
conversations you're feeling great about
everything and we'll just say you know
we just want to work with you
um we're totally agnostic to the idea
and come in and join us let's look at
10 12 15 ideas over the next three to
nine months if we find something we love
great let's start a company if we don't
find anything no harm no foul hopefully
you know you've met some cool people and
we've had fun along the way and
you know you're on to your next thing
and we'd love to be as supportive as we
can
one of the biggest differences between
sean and i although we're very similar
in a lot of ways he tends to do many
different things and he he likes doing
many things at one time
i
am always teasing him and and jokingly
criticizing him i'm like only do one
thing if you only do one thing you're
gonna be you're gonna succeed more and
he's like well no but i i like this and
it's working and he's right it is
working for him
you have both started one company or you
know milo was like your baby or i
imagine when you're running that that
was like your only focus
now your focus is on launching 10
companies a year although you know you
hire people to help you
make it happen so i guess your baby's
kind of atomic but
do you think that
starting multiple companies
is going to be a bigger wealth creator
for you than if had you just done kind
of one major thing and you only focus on
one
let's say a software company or
something like that
um it's an interesting question so
before i answer that just one comment on
that
i have noticed a pattern which is that
the smartest people i've met in the
world fall into one of those two camps
they either want to be like singularly
focused on one thing almost to a fault
where they are so focused on it and they
just absolutely have to crush it and
that's one archetype of success and it
works really well and some people are
super successful that are that way there
are other people and i put myself more
in the camp of like i just get energy
from working on a lot of things with a
lot of different people it's how my
brain works i have to work across a lot
of different things
and that's also you know part of it is
what you enjoy and what makes you happy
and
that's kind of what i enjoy and what
makes me happy it's inventing it's the
early stages it's what could come next
so when i thought about doing atomic it
actually wasn't believe it or not
a wealth building
exercise it was really
you know one is it possible to build a
company that builds companies nobody's
really figured out how to do that at
scale before two how could you do that
three is that the most interesting and
impactful problem in the world to work
on i believe that it was um at that time
and you know would it be fun and would i
get to work with really great people on
really great problems and i thought the
answer to those questions was yes so i
decided to do it um it can be very
lucrative
i do think
probably you can do better by just
focusing on one like if you had one
thing that was gonna go to the moon that
you can probably do financially
better just going all in on that thing
at least in the short term
um i don't know in the long term because
in the long term if you build a company
that builds companies
what's the value of that i don't know
it's like it's like asking a genie for
unlimited wishes
right
so but that's not really you know what
drove the decision making or kind of how
i think about it well you said it's not
been done before i mean um maybe i don't
know where they were at the time you
know rocket internet for those listeners
there's a company called rocket internet
based in
germany started by these three crazy
crazy brothers and their whole stick was
basically copy silicon valley companies
but do it in africa asia and other
places where that thing didn't so airbnb
in
europe or amazon and thailand or
whatever to zappos and uh nigeria
um and they
created a few companies that were
[__] huge and they did it so but they
the whole thing was copying to the point
of they would have this chief scientist
who would basically study let's say
they're copying pinterest he would send
out an email to the pinterest of africa
and the pinterest of germany and be like
pinterest changed their button size on
the top right from this to this
do it
have you ever thought what do you think
about those guys and have you ever
thought of doing that strategy where
instead of invention let's copy
yeah
so
it's just not our style it's a very
different style
first of all
i think the kind of talent you can work
with that you can motivate to just copy
other people's ideas i think is very
different
than the kinds of people we're able to
attract at atomic and work on our
companies you know it's more of a
mercenary probably than a mission-driven
approach
we pride ourselves in everything that
we've done has been innovative it's been
original we haven't been copying other
people's ideas it's not in our ethos to
do that so
and the processes and how it operates is
very different and the culture is very
different fundamentally as a result so i
do think you need to pick one of those
two things
would it be easier to build something
that just copies other people's ideas
yeah it would be easier but it probably
wouldn't work as well because i don't
think just copying other people's ideas
is as valuable and i don't think that it
would work as well anyway but it's also
just far less interesting to me
it seems like the ideas that worked well
for them were the ones where
there was like a local network effect in
the us that hadn't gone to europe yet
and they did it in europe before the u.s
company could go to europe
um but there were a lot of companies
that they copied that
they had a hard time because they kind
of installed someone who yeah there's
higher guns they would just hire bankers
and say just spend more money than this
other company exactly and uh
you know missionaries often outlast
mercenaries and
you have to longevity is one of the key
factors you need to to to win
let's talk about worked to some extent
but it's just different let's do a
couple minutes real quick on crypto so
great on a scale of one to chugging the
kool-aid where are you at with crypto
just kind of personally investing in it
and then what do you think is exciting
or or completely overrated i don't know
what your take is sort of it's pretty
polarizing so people are usually
very into it or you know think it's
toxic and and ponzi scheme so like where
where do you stand
yeah good question
i mean i think crypto is real and it's
here to stay um
i think the question is
what are the fundamental like real
innovations in crypto the things that
are going to be around and what are the
things that are there's a lot of
manipulation there's a lot of stuff
going on behind the scenes people don't
know about on these chat groups and apps
and like forums of like pump and dump
things yeah
really bad you know this is stuff that
people like in a normal market would
probably go to jail for
like seriously this is happening
somewhat regularly in this market so
it's a little concerning to like the
average person to know what is and what
isn't real
and that's my big concern with it is you
know there's a lot of people rushing
into it there's a lot of enthusiasm it
is real but knowing what is real and
what isn't real i think is is really
difficult
um so what's real to you what do you
think is real
so to me you know i think
one indicator to look for is where are
developers signing up
this is also true with companies by the
way whenever there's platforms that are
built and this is true for like
enterprise companies or like app stores
where do the developers go where the
developers go usually works and is a
good place to invest and i think that's
true of crypto as well
so on that thesis i think ethereum is a
great place to go solana seems to have a
lot of developer interest i think
there's a lot of other places
um you know one that i was kind of early
involved in and helped get off the
ground
was
one called tara and luna that just
launched a new main net that had like 50
to 100 apps just launched that are super
interesting
they're very interesting to me because
they're solving a different problem than
a lot of other people in crypto are
solving fundamentally what does that
mean
sorry go ahead go ahead
um
so
a lot of you know if you were to kind of
knock crypto if you were like a macro
economist and you were like wow what
does the world look like 10 or 20 years
from now if this really catches on the
big critique would be
well if this is digital gold imagine
what would have happened to the world if
everyone just held gold and nobody put
money into a bank
there'd be no jobs there'd be no economy
because people put money into the bank
the bank lends out money to companies
into people that money gets spent it
creates jobs those people spend the
money and it goes through the economy
and it just has this domino effect
that's really important for the whole
like system to work
in crypto someone puts it in crypto and
it stops and it doesn't keep traveling
through the economy it's not a
productive asset so you basically take a
productive asset and you make it
unproductive and i feel like for like
decentralized crypto to work and scale
in the world that's got to be fixed
somehow
and the tara and luna people are very
very attuned to this problem so instead
of just focusing on purely technical
things
like you know nfts or you know new apps
they can build or apis or smart
contracts or things like that they're
actually thinking about
you know how can you lend crypto how can
you borrow against crypto how can you
invest in stocks you can invest in
stocks directly with their stable coins
you can earn 20 interest with anchor you
can borrow against that and then there's
a way to earn 30 interest and there's
this whole ecosystem
of basically ways to make crypto
productive in a decentralized way within
the crypto ecosystem that i think is
really interesting and i don't know
they're really really good really smart
team i don't know of too many other
people that are working on that
and then the other one that i would call
out
that i was an early investor in is a
project that hasn't launched yet but if
there's anyone out there who knows how
to mine
i would say mine this cryptocurrency
it's called iron fish
and it's basically this genius
i can vouch for her she's a genius
and she basically created
what i what i think is the first true
cash on the internet so the whole idea
of crypto was it's going to be cash on
the internet
it's untraceable i give this to you
nobody knows just like with cash
in reality what happens with bitcoin we
make a transaction and it's public
forever literally this this record is
going to be public and replicated across
the internet forever and everybody's
going to know about it
now people realize that um and it's an
issue
so you had you know coins like zcash and
monero that were created but it turns
out those actually can be decrypted and
you can figure out where all of that
went so she's the first person that
really figured out how to make
truly anonymized crypto
and it's called iron fish i think it's a
really exciting project i don't think
it's tradable on exchanges but i think
it's mineable and it'll probably be
tradable at some point
those are some early ones that i think
are exciting worth um
worth kind of looking into
love it and uh
and do you use like defy are you like an
actual participant or user of defy
um i don't use d5 too much per se i'm
more i do actually a little bit but i'm
more of kind of like a set and forget it
buy and hold long term and patient
type of a person um so i'm not actively
doing i you know i know there's a lot of
stuff out there going on like yield
farming and things like that that
i'm not as attuned to um but if i had
more time i'd be interested in learning
more about it
yeah that's what i wanted to leave it
with which was if you weren't doing all
the [__] you're doing now
and i took away kind of the reputation
of the network so like you know you're
you're still you you're still you know
sharp but you're 21 22 23 years old
where do you think you would go work
what would you work on
hmm
that's an interesting question
i might consider
working on
you know web 3 and crypto specifically
figuring out how to use crypto to build
new networks
that can be built that are totally
decentralized um
like social networks or other types of
networks uh they could be marketplaces
they could be social networks but i
think what the internet taught us is
networks are what's valuable at the core
and i don't think web 3 is i think it's
still early there's like 10 million sort
of users out there of this stuff
there's you know four and a half billion
people on the internet so it still has a
long ways to grow if you can build some
of these early networks with network
effects you can probably build things
that are really valuable and i know
there are some people that are working
on it but there are probably still some
really interesting opportunities out
there
well this is this is this is awesome man
i i mean i could talk to you for another
few hours i've got so many more
questions hopefully you can come back
and do this again um of course we'd love
to thanks for having me this this is
badass um i'm i pay attention to
everything you guys do on an atomic i'm
always looking at your job page to see
like what are they who are they hiring
for now what are they going to launch
now and i'm trying to figure out if i
could kind of like reverse engineer and
see everything and so you have a good
taste dude you uh you you
invested in or co-incubated a company
with my cousin i don't know if you know
that uh rohan which one rohan puri he uh
yeah he's super smart yeah he's great
well thank you for doing this this is
badass um
of course thanks for having me we're
excited to publish this we're excited to
make this happen it was awesome talking
to you if people want to get more where
do they follow you find you
you know subscribe to your newsletter uh
buy your only fans what do you want them
to do
not on only fans
uh yeah you can follow yet uh you can
follow me on twitter
i'm just jack
jack abraham or you know you can find me
on linkedin
and or
you know we're just at atomic.vc is our
website you can actually apply on our
website for a program we have called the
future founders program where we'd love
to co-found companies with people we
love co-founding companies with diverse
people of all sorts of backgrounds we're
agnostic to location can be from
anywhere and we want to start a lot of
great companies and it'd be an honor to
start
you know maybe we can start
a company with someone listening to this
that would be great well this is awesome
thank you very much um
we'll uh we'll be sharing a bunch of
links i'm so excited you came on here
[Music]
you